uh my name is dr kyle kotwick i um
i'm really glad to be here after a
couple years of not being able to do
conferences it was a big part of my life
for a while so i'm thrilled to be back
into it i'm really happy to see a pretty
full audience so hopefully we'll have a
good time
so i'm here to talk to you today about
the boeing 737 max and i think most
people probably have heard about this it
was quite a thing in the media
back in 2019 just before covet became
the big topic
and we're talking about how humans don't
always necessarily mix well with the
technology that they're using
so i'll start a bit about me
i did my underground computer science
master's in electrical and computer
engineering and my phd in aerospace
engineering at mit
with a focus in human systems
integration
so that's why i have that's why you can
believe some of the things i'm saying
about this
uh i started my own company after i
graduated in victim labs we focus on
consulting and prototyping for complex
systems i do some human factors work as
well again in consulting and then some
software and infrastructure development
particularly in cloud systems
and we're based in ottawa the capital
city of canada that's where i live
quite beautiful at times until it starts
to look like
it does outside right now for most of
the winter
and i want to open by saying that what
we're going to talk about are things to
consider right i'm not going to give you
prescriptive directions on what you
should do or how you should build or how
you should design it we're going to talk
about things to think about right and
things that you need to consider when
you're designing systems
so a bit about human factors engineering
kind of my my specialty
and what it is and when i say this a lot
of people say i know what that is that's
ux and ui right
and yes it does encompass those um those
are two important components of it but
it's a lot more than that um and i got
to apologize in advance for my
powerpoint skills i am a back-end
designer i am not a front-end designer
um so forgive me there
uh biomechanics right so how human
bodies work and how they operate
cognitive processing how your mind
processes information and deals with it
sensory input how your different senses
collect and process information send it
to your brain
ergonomics so how human bodies fit into
technology and and how you build things
so that they are comfortable and don't
break
uh and then mental models which is
really how uh you make sure that what is
happening in your user's mind represents
what is happening in the system and that
they match properly and all this
together along with a bunch of other
fields is human factors engineering
and i want to talk about life critical
systems and i bring this up because i
think
probably
a large portion of the audience here
might be here because planes sound cool
and i want to hear about them and them
crashing
but maybe not so aware of how does this
actually relate to me and what i do in
my work
and uh so life critical systems
obviously anything that involves risk to
human life or that keeps someone alive
or could kill them
and i think a lot more people actually
work on these systems than might realize
it perhaps without even knowing about it
or without recognizing that it is life
critical
because we have aerospace uh you know
the hot topic of this talk um and
clearly we have organ of sorry av
avionics and navigation and engines and
all the mechanics of an aircraft are all
life critical because if they fail then
down it goes
but also every other component you might
not think about right the
timer on the coffee pot in the galley is
a life critical system it doesn't seem
like it but if that timer fails and the
software and it fails or the hardware
fails and the coffee boils over and goes
down through the floorboards and shorts
out some electronics or if it burns a
crew member that is essential for the
safe operation of the aircraft now it's
a life-critical system so there's a lot
of things like that you might not
consider but they really are
we have emergency services anything with
police or fire or medical um
clearly life critical not just the
knowledge and training of the operators
but the technology itself that they're
using
telecommunications is a big one if your
cell phone fails if the cell network
fails you can't call 9-1-1 in a lot of
countries elderly people uh rely on
being able to call in their
prescriptions to a pharmacy and have
them delivered can't do that if your
phone doesn't work
all sorts of things fail when when
communication fails
automotive right self-driving cars very
hot topic these days a lot of people in
here have probably worked on something
related to that
um your algorithm fails and your car
goes crashing into a wall at 100
kilometers an hour that's not that's not
going to be great
uh medical so when i bring up medical a
lot of people immediately think of
health devices right the things that are
connected uh ventilators and uh surgical
robots and things along those lines
but more often and i'm interested in
this one because i actually spent some
time working the medical field
it's actually the software uh that the
providers use for documentation that
causes the problems so imagine you have
a piece of software your your intake
nurse has to enter things like allergies
and medications the patient takes but
it's an unintuitive piece of software
they don't like the ways to design so
they just don't use it as intended and
then down the road your physician looks
at the patient's notes sees that the
allergy box is empty and gives a
medication thinking that that'll be fine
well the patient has an allergy to that
medication they die but it was never
recorded properly because the
documentation software had a problem
lots of things outside of what you
immediately think of as life critical
and of course military
anyone who's working an environment
where they're trying to you know end
lives is obviously life critical
and um not only is the hardware and
software itself intended for that
purpose but also it's being used in
environments that are very austere and
where it's being abused in ways that it
shouldn't be like smashed and through
extreme heat temperature ranges and all
sorts of issues that you have to think
so
it really covers a lot of different
topics and that's why i want you to
think that this does actually apply to
you as well
and i also want to mention that what
we're talking about is not theoretical
right
these events happened and a lot of
people died from them and while i have
some you know jokes throughout the
presentation to try to keep it fun and
interesting i just do ask that we keep
in mind that a lot of family suffered
from these and that it's a very
important topic
and i also want to mention that we're
not assigning citing blame here i'm not
an accident investigator so i don't have
that legal authority
and while it might sound like i'm
blaming a company that starts with bo
and ends with ing
i'm not so
please keep that in mind if you're
watching boeing's lawyers
so let's talk about what actually
happened uh so we have two crashes right
the first one lion air flight 610 in
october of 2018 so just over three years
ago
crashed into the java sea near indonesia
at 506 at least 560 kilometers an hour
that was the last recorded speed that
they uh were able to get from the flight
recorder from radar
but it probably was much faster than
that by the time it struck and that
killed all 189 passengers and crew on
board
and then ethiopian airlines flight 302
in about five months later six months
later and that crashed into terrain at
over 900 kilometers an hour playing all
157 aboard
now the impacts of this were massive
right the
737 was grounded worldwide starting
three days after the second crash not
sure why it took them three days to do
it but three days later um seventh sorry
387 aircraft were grounded which
affected 59 different airlines and 8 600
flights per week were canceled
and this aircraft was grounded for 20
months before it was recertified to fly
now
up until kovid this was the largest
thing that had ever impacted the airline
industry and
major economic impacts throughout
the audit of the federal aviation
administration the body in the united
states that certifies aircraft is safe
to fly
their process was clearly flawed as
we'll talk about later and so they
went under an audit from the government
to see why their process was flawed so
that caused some strife
and then we have uncertainty in other
regulatory bodies around the world so up
until this point different countries
their airline authorities or sorry
aviation safety authorities had said
okay the boeing aircraft is built in the
us the faa we trust them they certify it
so we're going to let it fly in our
airspace and trust that they've
certified it appropriately
well clearly they didn't so now um what
do all these other countries do does
every country now have to certify every
aircraft itself that's a major overhead
and time sink
and then looking at cost wise 20 billion
us dollars in fines for boeing alone
60 billion dollars in cancelled aircraft
orders so 80 billion dollars is a lot of
money to a company even like boeing that
is a huge chunk of their revenue
uh at least seven billion dollars in
cost to the airlines for the cost of
those flights not being able to fly and
having to maintain and store those
aircraft for that long
and a hundred million dollars in lost
income just for the pilots who weren't
allowed to fly because the aircraft
they're supposed to fly isn't allowed to
fly
so big impacts really had a an effect
around the world in the aviation
industry
let's talk about timeline uh so the
boeing 737 is kind of a legendary
aircraft
first released in 1967 so it's been
around 54 years it's
ingrained into aviation history
so in 2006 boeing says okay we've gone
through three generations of this
aircraft already it's time to replace it
it's getting old we need a new design
and so they plant what they call a clean
sheet meaning a clean piece of paper
you're starting from scratch
design for the replacement
and then in december 2010 airbus which
is boeing's main competitor launches the
a320 neo now the a320 is an aircraft
that is very similar to the 737 in terms
of size and capability and passengers
and range so it's a direct competitor
it's in the same market space
and so airbus launches the a320 neo and
neo stands for new engine option they
took their existing airframe and they
put newer much more efficient engines on
it
and this is very popular among the
airlines so the the neo sets a record of
730 aircraft sold at a single air show
and which is the most to date
and
the month after american airlines orders
260 of these neos and the really
important part here is that it breaks
their exclusivity with boeing up until
this point they had only operated boeing
aircraft and now all of a sudden they're
saying we are willing to go through the
logistics challenges the maintenance and
training programs and everything to take
this new aircraft because it is just
that appealing in the market
but they also say to boeing okay we
still like your 737 so we want some more
but we need them to have newer and more
efficient engines so they can match the
a320 neo and this really freaks out
boeing right because they're about to
lose one of the largest customers you
know they're breaking their exclusivity
they're not selling at trade shows and
they're really worried about losing
market share here
so they say okay
uh we need to build this version of a
737 with these new engines for american
airlines anyways why don't we just make
that our new product
and so they abandoned their idea of
building a complete replacement
and they focus on upgrading the existing
737 to a fourth generation which they
called the max
and then in 2016 the a320 neo has its
first revenue flight with an airline and
in 2017 the 737 max does the same and so
boeing pretty much accomplished their
objective they managed to get a new
product out to market that competes with
the 320 neo and get it flying within
roughly a year time frame
now before i go on i did see on the
speakers list that one of the speakers
here is actually an airline pilot is
that person here
up there okay
so uh
i'm curious afterwards to hear your
thoughts i'm sure there'll be some great
questions in the q a for about this
okay so why is this important why are we
talking about engines more efficient
engines are larger right so they take
more space because they're called high
bypass engines
here's an image of the original 737
engine from 1967 1.25 meters in diameter
you see it's pretty small it fits nicely
under the wing
here is the third generation
the uh from 1997 1.83 meters
substantially larger and you can see
that it's kind of moved forward and up
on the wing
and here's the 737 max 2.26 meters much
larger
now the question becomes how do you fit
an engine that is twice the diameter of
the original engine on the same airframe
and well you don't is the answer you
can't really do it
but you can kind of fudge it around so
that you can squeeze it in there somehow
so what they did here's a schematic that
shows a better view this is the original
you can see the engines are directly
under the wing
here's a second generation sorry third
generation you see they moved the
engines forward on the wing so they
could raise them up in front of the wing
that helps with the ground clearance
and here's the max you can see they
really took that concept to the extreme
and if you look at the top down view
those engines are so far forward they're
basically hanging off the front of the
wing and even after doing that you still
have a very small ground clearance of 43
centimeters
and from a side view you can see the
same thing just gives a better
impression of how far forward those
engines on the bottom are mounted
so why is this a problem why does it
matter
well the nacelles the casings that hold
the engines are actually what we call
lifting bodies they generate lift uh
when air moves past them
they're basically an extension of the
wing in that extent and what the problem
is that when you have something that
generates lift that's moved forward on
the aircraft now the front of your
aircraft wants to go up and this causes
your aircraft to pitch up and this is
particularly a problem or this issue
presented itself primarily when the
aircraft was what we at what we call
high angle of attack and the angle of
attack is a word you're going to hear a
lot and it means the angle of the
aircraft relative to the air that it is
moving through it is similar to pitch
related but not exactly the same because
it also depends on the direction of the
air
and so when the aircraft's at a high
angle of attack this issue becomes more
pronounced and so your aircraft pitches
up it causes lift at the front makes it
want to pitch up more and you have this
reinforcing loop that is not good and
the faa says no this is not okay you
can't do this you can't have an aircraft
that wants to pitch up on its own
without any pilot input
and boeing's own test pilots say the
same thing they say we're flying this it
feels off right it's not handling the
same as the old 737s it feels unstable
and this is a problem so boeing tries a
couple different things and they you
know they try to modify some
aerodynamics to handle this problem but
due to the age of the airframe and the
fact they can't really change it that
much without redesigning the whole thing
they can't do it so they decide to try
to fix this hardware problem in software
and we get what we call mcas the
maneuvering characteristics augmentation
system
mcas is an algorithm it's a piece of
software that sits and operates in the
flight computer
and what it does so here there's a
sensor on each side of the nose of the
aircraft this is the angle of attack
sensor and it measures the angle of the
aircraft relative to the air that is
moving through the flow of air i should
say
and this sensor is connected to the
flight computer where the mcas algorithm
is located
and the way it works is that this sensor
determines when the angle of attack is
too high and when it does it gives that
information to mcas which computes that
and says okay our angle of attack is too
high we need to activate the system to
bring the nose down and what it does is
it rotates the horizontal stabilizer
which is this black line in the tail of
the plane with the
circular red arrow it rotates it back
and that generates lift at the back of
the aircraft which brings the nose down
and tries to keep it stable
and so we have this nice closed-loop
system it checks it makes a compensation
checks it again and keeps going and
makes sure the aircraft remains stable
and this is great this deals with the
problem of too much lift at the front of
the aircraft causing it to continuously
pitch up
so let's put this on a
pretty little systems diagram
we have our flight control computers and
there's two of them in a 737 but only
one of them is connected at any given
time
and each one has its own angle of attack
center sensor
which is only connected to the computer
on that same side of the aircraft and so
the pilots can toggle between which
flight computer and therefore which
angle of attack sensor is active
but only one is active at a time
remember this is old legacy hardware
we're dealing with here mcas is an
algorithm that sits in this computer
and when it activates what it does is it
rotates that stabilizer which causes the
nose of the aircraft to go down and
we'll be modifying this diagram later so
we'll come back to this
i want to take a little break to talk
about something called type ratings
because they're very important in the
what happened here so a type is
basically a category of aircraft that uh
have similar characteristics and a type
rating is what allows a pilot to fly any
of the aircraft within that type
and type ratings are hard to get i mean
they take a lot of time and money your
pilot has to go through many hours in
ground school in a classroom they have
to do simulator training they have to do
an oral exam they have to do a check
ride and it's a long and intensive
process and airlines don't like this
they don't want their pilots to have to
do this if it's not necessary not only
because this equipment is very expensive
the simulators are many millions of
dollars but also because every hour that
a pilot is doing this training for a new
type rating is an hour that they're not
flying for the airline and therefore the
airline isn't generating any revenue so
it's a very expensive process so they
try to avoid this at all costs if they
can which is why you'll find that
airlines generally focus on a few
different types and try to keep it
restricted in the number that they have
and then we have what are called
variants
so the airbus a330 is a type
and within it are several different
variants so they're
similar aircraft they're slightly
different sizes
slightly different characteristics but
for the most part they're the same
and the a320 is also a type with several
different variants
and if we look at a picture of the
cockpits here so the a319 and the a321
are both variants within the a320 type
and we see why they're kind of treated
the same way the cockpits are almost
identical
similar displays controls um everything
flight handling characteristics are all
very similar
and so they basically treat it as if you
know one you can do the other pretty
easily
and so you're training to to move from
to move into a new variant if you
already have a type rating is very quick
it's usually an hour or so on a tablet
um and rarely any simulator training
required to do so
so it's low cost it's low time
commitment gives a lot of flexibility so
airlines love this feature and what's
important to note is that the a320 neo
this new aircraft that made boeing so
worried about market share
was given the same type rating as the
old a320s which meant that all the
airlines that had these old 320s all of
their pilots could immediately fly the
a320 neo with minimal training this is a
huge factor in making it a competitive
in the market
now the 737 also a type and all the
three previous generations of it
were that same type
and so boeing says okay well nuts if if
airbus was able to do this with the a320
neo we're not going to be able to
compete unless we do the same thing so
our new 737 max has to be in the same
type as a variant
the problem with this is that mcas is a
new control system and a new control
system means it requires different
training and different training means it
has a different type rating or gets
assigned a different type rating
and a different type rating means it's
no longer competitive and this makes
boeing extremely sad because they cannot
compete in the market and they will lose
all of their market share to airbus so
eric so boeing comes up with a solution
great solution they say
well the problem is
you know
it's mcas that requires the training so
what we're going to do is we're just not
going to tell anyone about mcas
because if you don't know about mcas you
obviously don't need to be trained on it
and if you don't need training you get
the same type rating as the older models
and if the same type rating
then you now have a competitive aircraft
again and this makes boeing extremely
happy because now they've achieved their
goals they've gotten something to market
pretty quickly that
is competitive with the a320 neo and
there are no major roadblocks all the
boxes are checked we're good to go
and this is something that boeing you
know recognized
so sorry before i go on i want to
mention that
you're going to see a bunch of quotes
here throughout the rest of the
presentation from a newspaper called the
seattle times as you may know boeing's
major manufacturing facilities have
historically been located around seattle
washington and the us
and uh so the seattle times has a long
and colorful history of covering boeing
uh aircraft uh and they've done an
excellent job of it for the most part
they actually won a pulitzer prize for
their coverage of the previous
generation of the 737 so that's why we
used them as a reputable source
so boeing decided that the pilots needed
no extra training on the system don't
even need to know about it not mentioned
in the flight manuals and that was done
to earn a common type rating with the
existing models so they could minimize
the training of the pilots nice recap of
what we just said and and boeing
recognizes this themselves
the ceo said mcas is fundamentally
embedded in the handling qualities of
the aircraft it is not a separate system
to be trained on right because your
pilot can't actually do anything
directly with it so why do they even
need to bother learning about it a
little spoiler alert here
mr millenberg is no longer the ceo of
boeing
and so the benefit here is that training
on moving from the old 737 to the new
one little more than one hour training
on an ipad no simulator required
airlines love it everyone's happy
so let's talk a bit about manual
override
something that always comes up when
we're talking about automated systems
particularly in software and hardware
and how they play together
this is the cockpit of the 737 max and a
couple things to note here so first we
have trim switches now on the side of
the yoke the
control column that the pilots use in a
boeing aircraft
is these little toggle switches and you
push them up in the plane trims so it
wants to go up you push it down and goes
down and it controls an electric motor
which rotates the stabilizer on the tail
and then we have the stabilizer trim
cutout switches these are two little
toggle switches at the bottom there and
if you turn these into the cutout
position if you flip them down then it
completely disables any electronic
control of the stabilizer
so that motor will no longer function
and then we have the manual trim wheel
this is right next to the pilot's knees
and it is a wheel that is mechanically
connected to the stabilizers there's
actually cables going between the wheel
and the stabilizer
so you can't disconnect it and you can
manually turn this wheel and rotate the
stabilizer and you'll see at the bottom
there's a little hand crank that flips
out
and that's how you would crank that
wheel if you needed to
let's add these components to our
diagram
we have our trim switches up here these
send a signal to the flight control
computers they run that electric motor
which rotates the stabilizer
and our cutout switches is around here
somewhere it completely disconnects any
electronic control of the stabilizer and
here we have our
manual wheel which is directly
mechanically linked to the stabilizer
can't be disabled always connected
so getting into the actual flights first
one lion air
this is a chart showing the
altitude and velocity of the aircraft
and hopefully people can see the
problems with this graph um about two
minutes in we have a sudden drop in
altitude spike in speed pilots recover
gain some altitude and then around five
minutes in for a six minute period we
have a
series of drops and gains in altitude
and then finally a plunge
into the ocean
and what's happening here is this mcas
system is kicking in gosh i'm going to
get that in that in a minute first i
want to show you
this is what a plane looks like after
crashes into the ocean at that speed
there's very little left and not only is
it very difficult to find and deal with
but there's very little to recover
meaning that it's extremely hard to find
the flight recorder or any other
components that can help you with the
accident investigation
so it's it's difficult to determine
these events and a lot of these events
that we're talking about are based off
of best estimates of what happened
but there's no guarantee that it's
necessarily correct
so what happened we suspect is that this
sensor the angle of attack sensor that
was connected to the flight control
computer that was active at the time was
broken and we think that it was broken
when it was installed prior to being
installed during the last maintenance
cycle
and
that sensor was feeding erroneous data
into the mcas algorithm
so mcas was saying oh no okay our angle
of attack is too high we must activate
because this is what we were created for
and we will activate and rotate the
stabilizer and that rotates the
stabilizer at the back and brings the
nose of the aircraft down
and the pilots they don't understand
what's happening because they're not
aware that the system even exists
so they try to use their electric trim
to counteract this right they press that
toggle switch activates the electric
motor rotate the stabilizer try to bring
the nose back up
um but
mcas is a very powerful system and it
activates for 10 seconds on five seconds
off while it reevaluates 10 seconds on
five seconds off and that's why you're
really seeing this this cycle right
because mcas is kicking in bringing it
down pilots are trying to recover
bringing it up and we're going back and
forth
but eventually the pilots start to panic
a bit and lose focus on what's going on
mcas
takes over and gets them into a dive
that is unrecoverable and they can't
save it from there
and we go into the ocean
and so that's what we can see happening
in this diagram here as well as a
reminder right we see the spikes in
altitude in uh velocity and dips in
altitude as this cycle happens
so after this crash the faa and boeing
get together and say what could have
happened and i think at this point
internally they're aware of the issue
but they still don't make it public but
they release what's called an air
worthiness directive which is basically
a bulletin that goes out to every
airline and pilot that operates this
aircraft to tell them of something
important about the aircraft they're
required to read it and understand it
and their directive says that if this
happens again in the event of runaway
trim you want to disengage the autopilot
control the pitch with the control
column and the electric trim toggle
switches and if after you've done that
relaxing the column causes the trim to
keep moving then set the stabilizer trim
switches to cut out those two toggle
switches i mentioned and if the runaway
continues hold the stabilizer trim wheel
against rotation and trim the plane
manually so they're just saying that in
the event that this starts to trim down
right try first disable the autopilot in
case that's the issue if it still
happens disable the automatic trim in
happens try to control it manually
and then we come to
ethiopia ethiopian airlines flight the
second crash and if we look at a graph
of altitude here we see it is very
similar striking similarities same
issues we see increases in altitude
followed by drops and increases and
drops this one's kind of interesting
because it shows a couple annotations of
some events that occurred over that
timeline
the
low altitude warning telling the pilot
to pull up requesting to return to the
airport for emergency landing and then
finally
diving down into the ground
and so this one collided into terrain at
like i said earlier over 900 kilometers
an hour this is what it looks like after
a plane hits the ground at that speed
uh again you know it's a bit easier than
a water recovery because at least the
pieces are still there and not sunk
below the ocean but trying to find them
and put them together is extremely
difficult there is very little remaining
so what happened on this one well
same issue this time they think it was a
bird that struck the sensor during
takeoff and broke the sensor
but it did the same thing it sent a
maxed out value
and said very high angle of attack mcas
activates
knows the plane goes down same issue
but this time those pilots have read
that error worthiness directives they're
aware that this can be a problem they're
aware of what they're supposed to do
so what they do
excuse me is they flip those cutout
switches to deactivate the electric trim
and they try to use their manual wheel
to rotate the stabilizer
but here's a problem
during takeoff a pilot has the aircraft
at full throttle and it's on the only
times during regular flight that you're
actually at full throttle
and what happened is because this issue
occurred shortly after takeoff the
pilots got distracted and forgot to
throttle back the engines and so this
aircraft was flying at full throttle for
quite a while and had reached a very
high speed
relative to where it was in the flight
and the altitude and what happens when
you're moving very fast through the air
and your control surface is already
tilted back as it is in this surface in
this in this image is that that's a lot
of air moving against that surface right
that's a lot of force pushing against it
and trying to counteract that force with
a little wheel next to your knee is
extremely difficult um and so what these
pilots they simply couldn't do it they
could not they could not apply enough
strength to that to rotate that
stabilizer
and so they recognized that and they
said okay the only way we're actually
going to be able to move the stabilizer
is to use the electric motor but to do
that we have to re-enable
those cutout switches
and then use our little electric trim
toggle switches again
problem being that this whole time mcas
was still running in the background it
just couldn't do anything because they
disabled the linkage between them
but as soon as they re-enable it to try
to use the trim switches mcas has an
effect again and it kicks back in and
just
drives them right down into the ground
and into an unrecoverable dive
now to recap the events
boeing modified an existing design which
changed the aerodynamics they couldn't
solve without a redesign so they solved
it in software they didn't tell the
pilots or airlines about us they
wouldn't have to be trained on it
pilots don't know what's happening and
that gives us accident number one
they provide the airworthiness directive
to tell the pilots that there could be
an issue they still don't say what the
issue is or what this algorithm is
that's causing problems but they say
just be aware there could be a bug in
the system
but the pilots are not physically able
to follow the instructions due to other
issues and we have accident number two
so this covers the events right this is
the story of what happened with these
planes and why and how they crashed
and now we're going to take this and ask
some questions about what does that mean
for us as engineers and developers what
do we need to think about from this what
are our takeaways
and the first question i want to ask is
when do you teach users about the inner
workings of a complex system
not just aviation but any any
complex high performance or life
critical system
obviously the question here is should
those pilots have been told about mcas
right from the start
so to illustrate this issue i want to
use an example let's say we have a
generic car okay a new model
but there's a factory defect and with a
low probability there can be this issue
where it just accelerates uncontrollably
by itself
it just keeps driving and accelerating
and you have two different ways to deal
with this deep inside the technical
manual for this vehicle you see option
number one the correct option and that
says that you need to hold the
accelerator pedal at its maximum point
for four seconds while simultaneously
pumping the brakes three times at one
second intervals you have to apply the
emergency brake at 33 percent
and hold it or release it after eight
seconds
and then after releasing the accelerator
but before releasing the emergency brake
you have to activate four-way hazard
flashers and apply the horn for 3.6
seconds
ridiculous example but
if you've ever seen a pilot's checklist
for certain issues that happen in flight
it gets pretty extreme
now the good thing is this is guaranteed
to resolve your issue 100 chance of
success if you do it right if you
recognize the issue and you apply the
procedure correctly it will solve your
problem
then you have option two which is turn
off your engine and attempt to control
the vehicle while you apply the brakes
and there's an 85 chance of success you
might go off a cliff but you'll probably
be fine
now say we have two users right we have
your average joe and he goes to the
dealership and says i want a new car and
the user says this is a great car for
you but just so you know has a small
little bug
and what should that dealer tell joe
about how to deal with this bug if it
comes up
the dealer has maybe
10 minutes to tell joe about it and then
joe's off on his way to drive this car
for the next 10 years what which option
does the dealer tell joe
then we have speedy sally here she's an
f1 race car driver
and uh she spends her entire career
training on these things right she
spends four hours a day studying
preparing practicing the other four
hours a day driving
and she's able to learn whatever you
tell her if you give her enough time to
memorize it and practice it how do you
assign these two different options to
these users
and i would say that normally you'd do
something like this right
joe
you're gonna tell him about it and then
if this issue occurs three or four years
down the road there isn't a chance in
hell that he's gonna actually remember
that procedure and how to apply it and
then actually be able to do it under
stressful situation
right
whereas sally
can probably do it because that's
exactly what she's trained for for the
last four years
and so this kind of gives the idea of
you don't necessarily want to train
someone on what is
the best option you want to train them
on what is the best for them
in their system for joe an 85 chance of
success is great because he doesn't have
to memorize anything this is just the
intuitive thing to do if your car starts
accelerating like that
whereas sally since she can't memorize
it and has the ability to do so uh we
give her the procedure that is
guaranteed to save her life
and these kind of form two endpoints on
what i call a performance versus
knowledge curve
on the x-axis we have performance or
complexity because those often go in
hand and on the y axis we have the
knowledge required to operate and
maintain a system
and sticking with our theme of
transportation let's plot some modes of
transportation we have walking very low
performance low level of knowledge
required to do it cycling's a bit higher
and then driving your car
you're getting into quite a bit of
performance but you actually have to
train and memorize some things you have
to do your driver's tests and training
and all that
and then we have our f1 car up at the
top
and it's not just cars our aircraft fit
the same model you have your little
cessna down at the bottom right your
beginner airplane that anyone can learn
to fly with a little bit of practice
and then you have your commercial
airliner a big step up in both
performance and knowledge and you have
your fighter jets up near the top where
you spend most of your time training and
just a little bit of time flying
and this applies not just to
transportation but all sorts of things
let's consider a cpu right you have your
stock 2.8 gigahertz quad-core cpu and
your laptop
that my grandmother can operate without
a problem
and she all she needs to know is if it
fails you turn it off and back on again
and it'll probably work
versus your overclocked cpu right in
order to do that i need to understand
how that works i need to know the the
methods required to achieve that i need
to know how to maintain it i need to
know about thermal issues and how to
resolve it if there's a problem
much higher performance but a much
higher level of knowledge required to do
it we have our little kitty skis strap
them on and go down the bunny hill not a
big deal versus your powder skis you got
to know not only your own not only how
to ski but also your boots how to do the
bindings how to tension them properly
and what to do if there's a problem
and then similarly you have your your
macbooks versus your linux computers
where you have a much higher performance
for a higher level of knowledge
and that
i get very different reactions to that
joke based on whether it's a front-end
developer conference or a
kind of more server-side conference so i
wasn't sure how it would go
uh so we put these on our on our graph
and uh we see that the trend holds right
and it's really consistent across most
different things in life that you might
build
now
the question being should the pilots
have been told about amcas coming back
to that
i don't know
because on one hand
yes these are experts who are operating
complex system who can train on it they
have the time to learn and memorize
procedures
and they know how to deal with these
types of issues so maybe you should tell
them on the other hand a commercial
airliner is an extraordinarily complex
piece of machinery that has so many
different subsystems and components that
could fail that there's no possible way
for one person to be able to memorize
all of it
so should they been told maybe
well let's look at what actually
happened
boeing concluded that there would be
little risk in the event of an mcas
failure in part because of an faa
approved assumption that the pilot would
respond to the issue in a mere three
seconds they're saying it's okay if it
fails because the pilot will recognize
it disable it take over manually it will
all be fine
but then they said
we're not going to inform the pilots
about mcas and the manuals even though
mowing safety analysis expected the
pilots to be the primary backstop in the
event the system went haywire they said
it's okay if it breaks
pilots will take over
they'll fix it but we're not going to
tell the pilots about it
and
again i'm not
signing blame with this but i think we
can see why this is a major issue in the
design not necessarily the design of the
aircraft but in the way that it was
handled and presented to the pilots in
terms of training and materials and
knowledge
so our second question then is how do
you ensure that users know what is
happening in this case you know we
assume that we tell the pilots about
amcas they're aware of it they know it's
a system that can break if it does break
or has a failure how do we make sure
that the pilot is aware of that
and this brings us to something in human
factors called mode confusion which is a
very hot topic it applies to any complex
system where humans operating it
particularly in aircraft and it's been
cited as a factor in i would say
probably the majority of aircraft
crashes in the last 50 years
so it's a very important topic um now in
an aircraft you have a lot of different
modes that aircraft can be operating and
you have an autopilot mode and you have
an auto throttle mode and those are not
necessarily the same thing you have a
takeoff configuration you have a landing
configuration and you have a dozen
different modes and configurations that
the aircraft can be operating in and in
these different modes sometimes the same
controls the same switches the same
displays do different things depending
on what mode it's in so if you're not
fully aware of what the system is doing
at any given time you might not know why
it's happening or how to deal with it
and this is before you even consider
things like mcas dancing around in the
background messing with your control
inputs without telling you
and so what happens is your pilot can
get very confused right they can say or
they cannot know why is the plane doing
this or not know how do i stop the plane
from doing this because they're not
aware of what the plane is thinking for
lack of better terms
and now i want to show a couple of
videos that kind of highlight this issue
it's a combination of mode confusion and
sensory input overload we call it where
you get so much information thrown at
you that you don't necessarily know what
to do with it or you can't process it
so these are from simulators this first
one is actually from an air france crash
seven
airbus a330 i believe
in 2009
they
did a simulation of the crash
uh for people sitting directly in front
of the speakers i recommend uh over your
ears for a sec
[Music]
over the next four and a half minutes
the stall warning will sound 75 times
it's supposed to be a bit louder you
might have turned it down a bit
um and then
here's so that's not directly related to
the boeing one but it gives you an idea
of how aggressive the alarm can be
here's another one this is from a 747
simulator
[Music]
so this gives you an idea of like how
difficult it is to operate in this kind
of situation these pilots can barely
communicate with each other let alone
focus on what they're supposed to do
there's an immense amount of information
being thrown at them and there's a huge
field of research on this about how to
avoid this issue how to design your
alarms and alerts and prioritize them
and make sure they communicate the right
information
in this video there are two alarms going
off
it's
expected that in the 737 crashes four or
five different alarms would have been
going off at a time just before they hit
the water so
obviously very difficult to focus in
those situations and really hard to tell
what your plane is doing and what your
system is doing and why it's doing it
and how to fix it
and just to summarize that uh during the
two fatal crashes that killed 346 people
the pilots struggled to understand all
the warnings that were being thrown at
them in the cockpit
what we have to remember about this is
this is not a new idea right this is not
an unknown this is not a surprise to
boeing or faa or anyone else uh this
there's an extensive field of research
over 40 50 60 years it really started
kicking in um
beginning during the apollo program was
when it became a huge field
and
the faa knew this right based on lessons
learned from past airline accidents
previous crashes the faa regulations
stipulate precise design details for the
warning displays that are aimed at
making sure the pilots know what is
going on that it catches their attention
and it averts any possible confusion
now number two here catching someone's
attention is very easy to do right you
make a loud alarm and it will catch your
attention but doing number one and three
in combination with number two becomes
quite difficult because
when you try to communicate some
detailed information to someone the best
way to do that is not allowed an
aggressive alarm that startles them
so these there's conflict here right
and these regulations these regulations
are written in blood like these are from
crashes where people died is why they
came up with these rules and yet in 2014
boeing convinced the faa to relax the
safety standards for the 737 max related
to the alerts that would warn the
cockpit if something went wrong or sorry
warn the pilots if something went wrong
during the flight
boeing's reason for asking for this
exemption was that the 737 design is too
old and it would cost way too much money
to bring it up to modern standards and
therefore we shouldn't have to do it
now think about that for a sec right if
you say that someone gives you a task
and you say i'm not going to meet your
specifications because it would
because the system's too old so i'm just
not going to do it and ignore them
especially in the life critical system
i think the issue here is pretty obvious
about why that's a problem in the design
manual override
this one's interesting because we know
that there was a manual override option
in the planes for the stabilizer right
they have that manual wheel that they
can turn and they have the cutoff
switches that disable the automation
so how does this apply to other systems
right as we're designing automated
systems how do we decide whether or not
there should be manual override whether
our user should have any input
whatsoever
so we have what are called levels of
automation and there are many different
published scales for this that go
anywhere from four to twelve different
levels of automation
but i've kind of summarized them into a
simpler version here
so four levels your first level being
providing helpful information a system
that tells you something that helps you
with your task right so think gps on
your phone or your navigation system in
your car it helps you do what you're
trying to do but it doesn't actually
control anything
then we have automatic control when
directed by a human so it's more like
your cruise control right it it turns on
when you turn it on it automates until
you turn it off and that's all there is
to it it doesn't do anything on its own
unless you tell it to
level three you have automatic control
unless directed by a human it's more
like your windows update right if you
don't do anything to intervene it will
update it will restart your computer and
off it goes on its own unless you
intervene to stop it
and then level four is your automatic
control with no human override this
one's kind of hard to think of an
example for because there are relatively
few systems in the world where there
isn't some sort of big red emergency
stop button to shut it down
um but you see this more in super
complex technical pieces of equipment or
things where there's very high latency
like spacecraft
which i remember the new horizons going
by pluto and taking those photos that
entire procedure was choreographed and
automated and there was no way that a
human could stop it once that program
was sent
so that's kind of an example of how that
works there
so where does mcas fit in this
right obviously it's not level two
because it occurs without a human doing
anything is level three or four
well there is a manual override so we'd
say three but you cannot enable your
manual override without also disabling a
lot of other important systems in this
case they could not disable mcas without
also disabling the electric trim motor
that they would need to rotate the
stabilizer back into position so is it
really a manual override if it breaks a
bunch of other things in your system
i don't i wouldn't i'd say it probably
is not
and so these are things you know i'm not
saying you should or should not choose
one of these levels of automation for
your your systems you're designing i'm
saying this is something you choose in
advance going in
with very careful planning
because you don't want to be dealing
with these issues down the road after
you've designed your system and you
start inserting things that fall in
different levels of automation here and
mess with your safety analysis
and uh which one you choose really
depends on a lot of different factors
from who your users are what level of
training they get what type of system
you're using and most importantly what
the consequences are if your automation
fails and you either can't intervene to
stop it or you can't intervene and do
something more effective uh so you know
a system that
if it fails doesn't hurt anyone it's
much more okay to have a fully automated
system than something that's like an
aircraft that will crash if it doesn't
so let's talk about redundancy now this
is further away from human factors and
human involvement at all but we've spent
all this time talking about the planes
and their designs so it's good to touch
on
hopefully in our diagram most people can
see the flaw in terms of redundancy
the two flight control computers are
redundant and they're there for that
exact reason and i believe they're
actually built with different components
different architectures different
software by different manufacturers to
make sure that if there's a bug in one
then hopefully it won't be replicated in
the other and you know you could switch
from one to the other to resolve the
issue
but each one is only connected to one
sensor
and if that sensor fails
the computer does not realize that and
therefore has no way to know that it
should switch to the backup computer
it can only be done manually
this
is a diagram showing the readings from
the two sensors on that aircraft the two
angle of attack sensors during the crash
the issue is pretty obvious the sensor
on the left broke early on and maxed out
its readings the sensor on the right was
working fine but the sensor on the left
was the one that was connected to the
active flight computer and therefore the
one that the aircraft was using for its
control inputs
so talking about redundancy what does
that mean well first off please don't
ever let a critical system have a single
point of failure right anyone in here
who does devops infrastructure high
availability work like that hopefully
you know already thinking about that and
incorporating that into your practices
thinking about
multi-regional architectures active
active failovers etc uh very important
part when you're talking about life
critical systems in particular
second don't let one broken sensor
affects good sensors
because what happens if the two sensors
disagree
in the graph i just showed you you know
some systems might say okay we're going
to average our two sensors and we'll
probably get an accurate reading well in
this case clearly that wouldn't have
worked either so it would have been very
erroneous data
so what do you do
ideally you add another sensor to do
some sort of voting mechanism
this is how a lot of distributed systems
work that you might be familiar with i
think apache zookeeper uses a similar
system to this to make decisions
and you know you can try to eliminate
the one that disagrees with the other
two and hopefully at least two out of
three will be valid
alternatively another approach is to
force a manual override so if you can
detect that your sensor is giving you
erroneous data
then maybe you can say all right i can't
trust this data i don't know what i'm
supposed to do so i'm just going to
deactivate the automation and let the
pilot take over the human operator of
whatever system take over
but imagine you're flying your plane and
you're focusing on something else like
your checklist or your navigation and
all of a sudden your autopilot
deactivates for this reason or any other
reason doesn't notify you and your plane
just starts drifting off to the side
and you have no idea why it did that why
it deactivated what the problem is
and now you get into mode confusion
which we talked about earlier and so you
see that these issues are often
connected in this web of messy problems
that are very difficult to solve when
you're trying to design
and again i don't have an easy answer
for you on how to do it you know adding
more sensors for voting costs more money
there's more parts that can break
trying to average data doesn't work like
there's no easy solution but you have to
think about what's going to be most
relevant to your design during the
design phase
let's talk about change management uh
this is a big one again not
necessarily related to human factors i
guess if you're considering the
developers as the humans then yes that
is human factors but not the pilots
in okay so with mcas specifically this
is an interesting one because the
original version of mcas uh was
activated only if two distinct sensors
indicated an extreme maneuver so it
required a high angle of attack and a
high g-force in order to trigger the
mcas algorithm in the initial design it
was designed as a backup in case the
plane somehow got out of its flight
envelope and was pitched up at a high
angle of attack
and this problem started to reinforce
itself and this system was there as a
safety measure to
cover for that
but what happened is that during the
flight testing the the um
test pilot said wait we love this this
is a great feature this makes it feel
more like the older 737s it makes it
feel more stable give us more mcas
and so boeing said okay we will do that
and they decided to extend the range of
when that system would operate into the
takeoff phase
because during takeoff you're naturally
at a very high angle of attack because
you're trying to go off the ground
and this problem is likely to be an
issue where where you have too much lift
in the front of the aircraft so they
said okay we're gonna use mcas for
takeoff but the problem is that at
takeoff you're moving pretty slow so
there's no excessive g-force
so what they had to do
is they had to remove the g-force sensor
as a trigger because then it wouldn't if
they left it it wouldn't have worked for
takeoff but that meant that mcas is now
activated by the single angle of attack
sensor so you've reduced it down to a
single point of failure
the other problem is that this is a
system that moves the control surfaces
of the aircraft the stabilizer to apply
aerodynamic forces
when you're moving at low speeds you
have to move a control surface more than
you would at high speed in order to have
the same force right because it's a
factor of the
movement of the control surface times
the airflow moving over it
so in order to for the system to work
during takeoff at low air speeds they
had to expand the range of motion of
mcas and how powerful it was
so when the planes entered service mcas
was capable of moving the tail four
times further than it was stated in the
initial safety analysis document
so they took a system that was designed
to be a safety feature they removed one
of the triggers so a single point of
failure they quadrupled the power that
it had and during this entire process
not once did they redo the safety
analysis so all of the faa's decisions
of what was okay about this was based
off an analysis that was based off a
design that was completely different
than the final design
and this i think is a complete failure
of change management right because all
these changes should have been connected
and triggered the new safety analysis
new reviews to make sure that all these
different implications
are considered
and then
finally i want to talk about retiring a
system
and i think anyone in who's worked on
like legacy legacy systems you know like
your 40 year old code from the bank or
something else that simply doesn't even
exist anymore and it's hard to find
someone who even knows the technology
will recognize that there are points
where you simply can't push something
any further without it becoming very
fragile or risky or having some other
problem
boeing had that thought right they they
knew that their 737 had already gone
through three generations and it was
time to build a new design
and that was what they were going to do
but due to market pressures and
competition and the lack of oversight
from the faa
they were able to build a fourth
generation of the 737 and really pushed
that boundary further than it should
have been pushed and built what was at
the time an unsafe aircraft
and so i think this is important for us
as engineers to really consider you know
if we're asked to work on a system like
that you know just just patch that bug
don't worry about the rest of it it'll
be fine even though it's 50 years old
that's a risk right and that is
something that we can't just accept
blindly as something that'll be okay
and we really need to consider it when
we're working on projects
and i want to close with a brief mention
on what our responsibilities are uh in
these types of environments
so realistically you know as if you're a
freelancer particularly but even working
for a large company
you're never going to be in a position
as a developer where you are responsible
for seeing the overall picture and how
these components interact with each
other you know that is a job that there
are specific roles for systems engineers
integration engineers who do exactly
that to make sure it works
but that doesn't mean we're just off the
hook entirely and can just follow
specifications blindly to do
to build something that slots into a
module in a life critical system and
expect it'll be okay
and i think that
it kind of falls to us to
recognize when something might be a
problem you know if someone says please
quadruple the power of this control
system and then just do it and not say
is this going to interact with anything
else is this going to cause any problems
um is it a little uh
well it's something we
you need to consider and be okay with
the idea of questioning that
and asking the tough questions is this
going to be safe
and if your employer discourages that or
has a problem with that then i recommend
you find a new employer
because what i guarantee you don't want
is to be in the situation that a bunch
of boeing engineers are right now where
they regret a lot of decisions and have
quite a weight on their conscience for
the rest of their careers
so with that i want to thank you for
your time and uh hopefully you enjoyed
this presentation and the topics we
covered i know it's kind of a little
depressing and morbid at times but
important stuff to consider and
hopefully some some things for you to
take forward into future positions thank
you
oh
my mic is off
let's see i have six minutes if anyone
has any questions i'm happy to answer
also you know keep going don't worry
about leaving but if there are any
questions i'm happy to take them yes uh
what happened to the plane
yes the plane is back in service uh it
was approved the funny thing about it is
i would say that the the 737 max is now
probably the safest aircraft in the sky
because it is the only aircraft that has
gone through such extensive review of
every component in it
because no one was going to let another
problem slip through so yes it is
approved and flying i actually flew on
one coming here
[Laughter]
any other questions
i can't see sorry lights
yes there
sir how come the test pilots didn't
run into the same problems well because
these problems so for the most part they
loved mcas as i mentioned because it it
compensated for that problem with the
aerodynamics so the plane felt more
stable when encase was doing its thing
but the problems occurred
when the sensors broke and the sensors
breaking was not part of the test plan
so i think boeing's initial safety
analysis estimated this problem at like
happening in one and one trillion flight
hours or something like that um so it
wasn't part of the test plan and even
then the impact they considered a
a major effect which is actually a
relatively low category below a
hazardous and catastrophic effect
yeah their scale is a little wonky but
um so even though so it was a low
probability and a low effect so they
said we're not even going to bother
testing these systems
yeah
yeah if you have your hand up just shout
out because i can't see it with the
lights
or just informed pilots
uh they changed the algorithm um i'm not
sure exactly what they did on a hardware
side i know they modified the algorithm
and i believe they set it up to um
so there's actually an interesting thing
where the uh
that plane was sold with an optional
package
it was not included in the base model
and if you notice the two crashes were
by kind of low budget airlines and they
had purchased the lowest cost aircraft
so they didn't purchase this optional
package which actually reads the data
from the two sensors the two angle of
attack sensors and compares them to and
gives an alert if there's a disagreement
it's called a disagree alert and it
shows a light saying these sensors one
of them is out of whack
so they did not
include that in the base model i believe
one of the things they changed was they
made that part of the standard package
along with some other changes they
changed the software and i think they
may have connected the two sensors so
that they're both always connected to
both computers but i'd have to double
check that one
yeah
all right well thank you very much again
and uh
if you see me later feel free to strike
up a conversation about this because i
enjoy talking about it